there is a girl hanging by her broken
leg from the telephone wire
[Music]
we're gonna need several ambulances
how many people three you really need to
hurry
[Music]
so everything happened on May 22nd 2021
he was by boyfriend yeah we just broken
up two days
I was stupid and driving crying it was
just him I was crying over which is so
embarrassing everyone was always like
why are you crying and it's like I was
stupid and emotional we went up for the
base of the mountain towards the sunset
and we sat there for a while and then we
started heading out probably 9 10
because one friend's mom called and told
me to be at home by 9 30.
we've got to have ambulances and police
out here right away what's going on
a car wreck
I lost control of the vehicle left of
the road and so I went off and I over
corrected and I overflipped it too far
and went too far off the road on the
right and that's when my car caught
somewhere and the left side of the car
hit the right chunk of the waterfall and
took a trunk out but flipped us sideways
before we started flipping and rolling
I just kept flipping and moving when I
was rejected out immediately almost
some people are very shocked that
someone would take a picture before they
got me down and people are like oh are
you mad that they take a picture no I'm
not no one will believe me if I didn't
have that picture people still don't
believe me and I have the picture a girl
is hanging by her leg from the telephone
pole wire there's multiple people hurt
all right stay on the phone with me
I'm gonna get the ambulance and
everything head in that direction I'm
going to get more information from you
we're gonna need several ambulance
there was nothing they could have done
for me before the ladder truck got there
that's how they got me down was with the
ladder truck from what I understand the
letter truck took a while to get there
because the 9-1-1 call wasn't understood
correctly or possible two vehicle
crashed
one female with a possible broken leg
your ambulance is coming how many
vehicles
one
[Music]
I was conscious the whole time I knew I
was upside down super high in the air
because I was up there for an hour what
did I get to me I just hung there
I was not wearing a seatbelt and I know
like it's a sensitive topic and I say
that people get really upset and say it
was dessert
I think just the momentum of the core
rolling it was like it tore off my door
my side of the door the windshield was
cracked in so we don't know where I went
out but I would guess probably the duel
but we think that's when my arm got
mostly ripped off was coming out of the
vehicle
but it was hanging on by the skin on my
back still so just that's how they were
able to reattach it
I had two friends in the vehicle the one
in the passenger seat she suffered with
a we had a broken neck broken back and a
broken pelvis the front in the back he
had a broken neck and pelvis
I don't remember when we crushed I just
remember I was crying and then recently
I can remember the screams in like the
break-in of the glass in the middle when
we crashed along the people are in bad
shape hold on Chris you got help coming
I'm still alive
probably the most traumatizing thing of
the whole experience was just looking
and turning and looking and seeing
Kennedy up in the line like I my brain
could not even understand how she got up
there
this is my left leg all tangled up in
the wire this is my knee joy and then
this part where it's bent is where my
femur was busted in half and that's
where the wire was all tangled in people
were asking like what happened and I
didn't believe in we'll post a picture
and people were like this isn't real
you're lying you were going 100 miles an
hour you were you would have been drunk
you have been on your phone you would
have been this you would have been that
there's like in all these accusations
thank you
I ended up suffering from a brachial
plexus injury so that left me with
little to no function in my arm my
collarbone was not my healing for snap
and then I ended up losing my leg due to
the lack of blood flow for creaming in
the power line for anywhere
[Music]
a prosthetic is so hard like it's hard
because not only is it like the way you
get around all day every day
also takes a lot of energy to even get
places
your leg
it's definitely very hard
[Music]
so I thought I would show you guys how I
put it on and how I run with it how I
get this off is I use this tool
I stick it in here
and I just unscrew
I then do this top one
[Music]
and it just comes off I then stick the
running blade in and screw this back in
now that we've got this leg off and this
one on now we can go running and this is
so much heavier than this one this is so
light and bouncy a little backstory is I
used to have any in this and I could not
figure out how to run with it in I then
went to a running clinic and they took
their knee out and I learned how to run
in two to three hours they taught me a
few exercises and I could slowly put it
together and so running in place
like this and I have to circumduct in
order to run
[Music]
I only got this set up a week and a half
ago to two weeks and so I'm still
learning I still don't have the speed
I'm just getting it all down and trying
to put it all together if I can find the
motivation to use this blade and go on
the runs you guys can too and I just
hope this is an inspiration to go out
and move your body
if you go through something hard you get
to choose
what hard you want because being sad and
sitting around and like feeling sorry
for yourself that's hard or you can
decide to take what you have make the
best out of it and work your butt off
and that's still gonna be hard so why
are you gonna sit in your bed and cry
about it when you can do something about
it and change others lives and like help
them go through things like you have any
messages I've got about girls or people
that have gone through similar
situations that that they're like your
account has helped me so much or it's
gave me hope that my body will heal just
as well as yours did it and like just
that makes me so happy that I can like
help people and give people hope
I felt a sharp pain on my ankle
and then nothing else it felt like
forever I I was I felt like I was under
there for 20 minutes but it was more 20
seconds
it wasn't long at all when I was under
the water I knew that my dad was gonna
come get me she rubbed my forehead she's
like we're gonna have to take your leg